Welcome to Part 2 of 6.004x!
In this part of the course, we turn our attention
to the design and implementation of digital
systems that can perform useful computations
on different types of binary data.
We'll come up with a general-purpose design
for these systems, we which we call "computers",
so that they can serve as useful tools in
many diverse application areas.
Computers were first used to perform numeric
calculations in science and engineering, but
today they are used as the central control
element in any system where complex behavior
is required.
We have a lot to do in this chapter, so let's
get started!
Suppose we want to design a system to compute
the factorial function on some numeric argument
N.
N! is defined as the product of N times N-1
times N-2, and so on down to 1.
We can use a programming language like C to
describe the sequence of operations necessary
to perform the factorial computation.
In this program there are two variables, "a"
and "b".
"a" is used to accumulate the answer as we
compute it step-by-step.
"b" is used to hold the next value we need
to multiply.
"b" starts with the value of the numeric argument
N.
The DO loop is where the work gets done: on
each loop iteration we perform one of the
multiplies from the factorial formula, updating
the value of the accumulator "a" with the
result, then decrementing "b" in preparation
for the next loop iteration.
If we want to implement a digital system that
performs this sequence of operations, it makes
sense to use sequential logic!
Here's the state transition diagram for a
high-level finite-state machine designed to
perform the necessary computations in the
desired order.
We call this a high-level FSM since the "outputs"
of each state are more than simple logic levels.
They are formulas indicating operations to
be performed on source variables, storing
the result in a destination variable.
The sequence of states visited while the FSM
is running mirrors the steps performed by
the execution of the C program.
The FSM repeats the LOOP state until the new
value to be stored in "b" is equal to 0, at
which point the FSM transitions into the final
DONE state.
The high-level FSM is useful when designing
the circuitry necessary to implement the desired
computation using our digital logic building
blocks.
We'll use 32-bit D-registers to hold the "a"
and "b" values.
And we'll need a 2-bit D-register to hold
the 2-bit encoding of the current state, i.e.,
the encoding for either START, LOOP or DONE.
We'll include logic to compute the inputs
required to implement the correct state transitions.
In this case, we need to know if the new value
for "b" is zero or not.
And, finally, we'll need logic to perform
multiply and decrement, and to select which
value should be loaded into the "a" and "b"
registers at the end of each FSM cycle.
Let's start by designing the logic that implements
the desired computations - we call this part
of the logic the "datapath".
First we'll need two 32-bit D-registers to
hold the "a" and "b" values.
Then we'll draw the combinational logic blocks
needed to compute the values to be stored
in those registers.
In the START state , we need the constant
1 to load into the "a" register and the constant
N to load into the "b" register.
In the LOOP state, we need to compute a*b
for the "a" register and b-1 for the "b" register.
Finally, in the DONE state , we need to be
able to reload each register with its current
value.
We'll use multiplexers to select the appropriate
value to load into each of the data registers.
These multiplexers are controlled by 2-bit
select signals that choose which of the three
32-bit input values will be the 32-bit value
to be loaded into the register.
So by choosing the appropriate values for
WASEL and WBSEL, we can make the datapath
compute the desired values at each step in
the FSM's operation.
Next we'll add the combinational logic needed
to control the FSM's state transitions.
In this case, we need to test if the new value
to be loaded into the "b" register is zero.
The Z signal from the datapath will be 1 if
that's the case and 0 otherwise.
Now we're all set to add the hardware for
the control FSM, which has one input (Z) from
the datapath and generates two 2-bit outputs
(WASEL and WBSEL) to control the datapath.
Here's the truth table for the FSM's combinational
logic.
S is the current state, encoded as a 2-bit
value, and S' is the next state.
Using our skills from Part 1 of the course,
we're ready to draw a schematic for the system!
We know how to design the appropriate multiplier
and decrement circuitry.
And we can use our standard register-and-ROM
implementation for the control FSM.
The Z signal from the datapath is combined
with the 2 bits of current state to form the
3 inputs to the combinational logic, in this
case realized by a read-only memory with 2^3=8
locations.
Each ROM location has the appropriate values
for the 6 output bits: 2 bits each for WASEL,
WBSEL, and next state.
The table on the right shows the ROM contents,
which are easily determined from the table
on the previous slide.